let's say i visit your home country what
is like the one
dish that you would make sure i had to
have while i was out there whether it's
at a specific restaurant or some home
cooking what's the dish man
right off the bat i would say uh
i'd say fried rice
okay i would have said jello fries but
like
i think fried rice is more fun okay and
like uh
there's something called suya it's like
a it's like a type of meat
it's like beef but it's like dipped in
some spicy sauce and stuff and it sounds
amazing it's roasted over like an open
fire wow and it's it's real spicy though
but you're gonna love it
while you're in la somebody needs to
take you to a taco truck
that's yes someone has to somebody you
gotta take him to leo's taco truck
you gotta get some carne asada some el
pastor
you gotta tap into some of this mexican
food in l.a yeah i had hot tacos in
miami though no no no tacos in miami
that sounds like a terrible idea oh
really what
no no no okay no i hear you that's like
saying you had
like lobster in oklahoma or something
they'd be like there's no water nearby
that can how fresh could it really be
yeah no you get
while in cali you gotta get real mexican
food
because it's the best
yeah right not my when you're in miami
you get cuban food
or lobster no one told me [ __ ]
i lived in florida and it's the worst
mexican food ever it's terrible but